l' affaire grégory gardera son mystère
on a appris aujourd'hui que les traces d
adn prélevé sur une lettre du corbeau
sont inutilisables
la famille du petit garçon retrouvé noyé
dans la vologne
il ya 16 ans espérait que les progrès de
la science elle et permettre d'établir
la vérité dominique dumas les parents et
grands parents du petit grégory villemin
avait mis beaucoup d'espoir dans cette
démarche scientifique qui les avait
demandé 16 ans après le drame
l'analyse génétique de traces de salive
sur un demi timbre d'une lettre anonyme
envoyée en 83 n'a pas permis
d'identifier l'auteur le corbeau qui
harcelait la famille villemin avait
écrit une dernière missive revendiquant
l'assassinât du petit garçon retrouvé
mort le 16 octobre 84 on nous dit que
c'est ininterprétable inexploitables par
conséquent malheureusement c'est le
réseau qui tombe sur l'affairé gorille
je crois qu'on ne connaîtra jamais l
assassin de cet enfant dans cette
affaire deux personnes avaient été
inculpées bernard laroche un cousin
finalement innocentés et tué par jean
marie villemin le 29 mars 85 et
christine la mère de grégory blanchi le
3 février 93 par un non lieu
kiss-in obtient non lieu qui proclame
son innocence absolue mais ça ne
suffisait pas un seul jeune femme elle
voulait l'entière vérité
elles ont pour laquelle fin novembre 99
g engagé ce processus visant à fait
réaliser une expertise génétique
malheureusement la science baisse les
bras la chambre d'accusation de la cour
d'appel de dijon avait donc ré ouvert le
dossier le 14 juin dernier pour procéder
à cette analyse génétique aucun adn n'a
pu être véritablement visualiser selon
l'expression des experts probablement
c'est lié à la manipulation excessive de
dessus de cette enveloppe qui comptait
ce fameux demi timbre mais pour la
justice il fallait exploiter toutes les
pistes possibles pour trouver la vérité
l' affaire grégory et prescriptibles en